hey Paul how are you hey Dave thank you
for taking my call I'm sure thank you
for what you do thank you so I want to
tell you I really appreciate what you do
I gave my kids my grown kids the
Financial Peace University because
really endorse what you do and I wanted
them to share in that inheritance thank
you how can I help today my question is
this I'm 59 my 58 we are completely
debt-free within the next few years
going to be looking at stepping mail for
full-time positions
I was recently approached friend of mine
through my realtor that connected me
with this guy Deb's houses
professionally and we connected and he
asked me about partnering with him
financially and getting a percentage of
the return on that and I want to know
your opinion on that what's your flip
the number of houses that have not done
it in a number of years and so he's
connected me with him okay so you have
the cash to do this yes right there in
cash yes sir
okay all right well I you probably it
sounds like you've been around me enough
to know I'm not fond of partnerships I
think the only ship they won't sales a
partnership yes and it's a really really
good way to get burned if you structure
this wrong there is a way to share in
the profits and make it more of a joint
venture if you want to do these kinds of
deals if I were in your shoes the way I
would structure it is he finds the house
and you buy the house and own the house
and if there are funds dispersed to do
the remodel that he's managing then
you're going to disperse those funds but
you're only going to disperse them as
the remodel occurs right yes sir you
know just give him a check and hope he
does it and so at any point in that
process if he just leaves the planet and
takes off to somewhere else you don't
really have to find him
you've just got to finish the house out
and sell it and you won't get burned
because you're the owner of the house
and then let's say he does follow
through and there's not any problems and
you end up you know after renovation
with a hundred thousand dollars invested
in a property that's worth two hundred
thousand and you sell it you could split
the profits at the closing table and he
gets half of the profits when the
property closes only no other time okay
and until it sells in other words the
house is not flipped until it sells
that's correct
where these things get out where people
get burned is when they don't flip or
when they get halfway through and they
lose their emotional energy to complete
and the financial partner is the one
that gets burned but he could get for
his hustle for finding the deal managing
the renovation managing the resale and
in a sense you become a quote silent
financial partner in return for his
hustle he gets a percentage of the
profits half or otherwise you can decide
doesn't have to be half but whatever you
decide that that is a you know an
agreement between the two of you as a
joint venture and he can get paid for
that legally without a real estate
license for digging up the deal getting
the property sold now you can't get paid
a real estate commission that's illegal
in every state unless he has a license
but he can get paid when the property
closes on the resale until then sir
you're at risk okay but if he wants to
be joint owner with you in an LLC no I
wouldn't do it okay you don't need him
that bad no and I think a question that
I had was I because I am buying rentals
as a part of my retirement income I was
curious if I would be better off taking
that money and going ahead and put it
into another rental versus putting it in
and invest it with him well it depends
on the numbers yeah if he's if he is
getting some really good deals on
properties
and he's a real bird dog he knows how to
turn over the turn over the rocks and
get the rabbits to run out you know you
might make some quick money you might
turn your I mean what's the what's the
amount of money allocated for this next
rental deal for that you've gotten mine
uh well I was twenty sixteen hundred
thousand okay let's say let's say you
dropped a hundred thousand in like I was
talking about a while ago and you were
able to add twenty-five or thirty to
that on one flip that would change the
whole complexion of your rental purchase
right if you even if interested on with
him but if you're not going to make that
if you're going to make five thousand
bucks on a flip net to you after it's
all done heck with that
that's not worth the trouble so you guys
need to be buying on flips you got about
seventy percent of value minus repairs
or you're going to lose money on flip
eventually yes and if you can't buy that
then you're not going to be in a deal
and it's not it's not going to work for
you so that means you're literally
buying a you know a two hundred thousand
dollar property for a hundred and forty
minus repairs okay or you don't do the
deal so you know because you're going to
by the time you do resell and you got
commissions and you could have had the
money making money while you're sitting
on it and so there's lost opportunity
cost on the money you've got closing
costs on the purchase closing costs on
the resale you got property taxes and
insurance you've got the fact that you
always miss your construction estimate
unless you've done a hundred of these
and by the time you finish all of that
you know you're what sounds like a
thirty percent gross margin didn't even
close and so if you're going to make
five or ten thousand bucks I wouldn't
screw with it okay but if you could make
some if he can walk you into a sweet
deal as long as you maintain the
ownership position I'm fine with it but
if he starts doing some kind of you know
twisted sideways deal where he wants you
to finance something and you know all
this kind of you just needs your
signature
Oh Lord you're about to get taken to the
cleaners okay
well that was part of what we can talk
about now I just move on and let's see
unless you can get this deal real clean
and simple but but listen it hi I used
to do this I used to be the bird dog
after I'm
broke I knew how to dig up deals that's
I never had trouble digging up deals and
so I would dig up deals and I would
either put guys into the deal and make a
spread on the front end like you know if
he brought you a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar house for a hundred
you'd pay him ten grand for that deal
and he could walk away and you'd have a
rental right yeah yeah easy you'd be
happy to close on that at one hundred
and ten and so on so I did stuff like
that and I did stuff where I actually
helped people buy the property they own
the property and when we flipped it I
made some money off the back but I never
asked them to finance it for me oh
that's just a nightmare this is the Dave
Ramsey show